- Let's get some practice counting money!
So I have six coins right over here,
and these are all United States coins,
we're counting money in the United States
for these examples, and
what is this first coin?
Well, this is called a
quarter, or a quarter-dollar,
so it represents 25 cents,
and we could write it out
as 25 cents, but I'll just
keep that one like that.
Now this one's another quarter,
so it is also going to be 25 cents.
Now this one looks different, but
it's just the other side of these coins.
This is what the other side looks like.
So this is also going to be 25 cents.
These are three quarters right over here.
So how much money do these
three quarters represent?
Well, it's going to be
25 plus 25, which is 50,
plus 25, which is going to be 75,
so these three quarters
are going to be 75 cents.
And remember, 100 cents make a dollar,
so this is still less than one dollar.
But we're not done yet.
We have this nickel, this
is a nickel right over here,
that represents five
cents, and then we have
another nickel here, it looks
different, but it's just
the other side, this is the head
side, this is the tail side.
So this is also another five cents,
and so these two nickels,
if you add them together,
they are going to represent 10 cents,
and then finally, you
have a penny, and a penny,
and it even says it right over
here, is one cent, in fact,
they all say it here, this is
five cents, this is one cent.
So this right over
here's gonna be one cent.
So what is 75 plus 10 plus 1?
Well 75 plus 10 is 85, plus 1 is 86,
so this is equal to 86 cents.
And if it felt a little bit
too fast to count up 25, 50, 75
in your head, you could also add them up.
25, 25, 25, plus 5, another 5, plus 1.
You could add them up this way,
and then what would you get?
5 plus 5 is 10, plus 5 is 15,
plus 5 is 20, plus 5 is 25,
plus 1 is 26, so that's
two tens and one six,
put the two tens up here.
2 plus 2 is 4, 4 plus
2 is 6, 6 plus 2 is 8.
So you could get 86 cents, either way.
Let's do one that has
even more coins in it.
So here we go, we have, so what
is it, what's going on here?
This right over here is a quarter,
that's going to be 25 cents.
25 cents, and then, we
have one that we didn't see
in the previous example,
we have two dimes.
A dime represents 10 cents,
so we have two dimes,
where we can have those
each represent 10 cents,
then we have two nickels,
we've already seen
those each represent
five cents, so 5 and 5,
and then we have four pennies,
one, two, three, four.
Now we could put each penny
separately, like that,
or we could say, look, four
pennies, each of them represent
one cent, so that's
going to be four cents.
So let me do it that way.
So, this one, two, three, four,
that's going to be four cents.
And then we could just add everything up,
so 5 plus 0 plus 0 plus 5 is
10, plus 5 is 15, plus 4 is 19.
19 is one ten and nine ones, so I could
put the one ten in the tens place,
1 plus 2 is 3, plus 1 is 4, plus 1 is 5.
So it's five tens, five tens
and nine ones, so 59 cents.
This right over here is 59 cents.
And notice, we have more coins,
but it represents less value
than the previous example.
That's because we had a lot of coins
that didn't represent a lot of values,
like, we had these four pennies here,
while the previous example,
we had three quarters!
Each of these quarters is
equivalent to 25 pennies,
so we're able to represent more money
with fewer coins in the first example.